hello and welcome to this video
they had no may I dad Rock okay
complicated name
maybe not pronouncing it right anyway so
we have a very soft opening that is the
combination of 93 and Bishop g5 c5 I
think is good reply to that taking okay
it looks a bit odd here for white that
cannot be an advantage for white I guess
so c5 there sorry I mean f5 keep the
night away and then Queen a5 looks like
a simple recipe there is one problem
here for white I mean more than one but
one is particularly pressing I will quit
it you I will take on c5 next and yeah
how is he developing the bishop he has
to move and III or c3 and this is not
nice to play if you don't have a dark
squared Bishop this is going to be the
problem here that what we can his pawn
structure quite significantly the only
thing is yes he castles long and there
might be there might be an issue here
with my development we should be the g7
is what I would like to play but he's
got night age five that's actually an
issue there it's a real problem
they don't want to play e5 here really
because it is so slow it's not entirely
clear orders because of my development
yeah maybe even critiques okay I can
take play Bishop c5 that is a concrete
issue yeah okay now really now there is
Bishop h6 oh yeah of course I couldn't
do it before now you know he just gives
it up just gives me the pawn give to me
the pawn yep I happily oblige um the
ship is six I guess so it's their tactic
or something I don't know don't think so
should be six maybe night before now
it's already on the agenda yeah I think
it is really you don't need to react to
it
okay how do you cover over everything
now here a to c2
it's just gone right how do you cover
this see to us hanging
yeah well I can't even take it
but if I just move the king
maybe I could have taken it Queen takes
some but okay I still don't see what
he's doing now
okay that is a move um maybe f4 how do
you do that I mean Queen takes b5 it
takes Bishop a - King a one-night
situate
but it doesn't doesn't really help does
it work
you see threatening anything maybe
Knight f5 can go F form I can also just
take C form you have it it doesn't it's
that how convincing is that I said I'll
see how he covers everything Bishop
takes Queen takes Queen III Queen eight
you can see one Queen a one check King
here could be two knights it - I win the
Queen at the end that's one line and
yeah I mean Bishop e2 yeah okay and
again a - there is no b3 and Queen a2 is
made so with the bishop on e3 not much
not much to do essentially I'm attacking
here with Queen and two minor pieces
while those two are not doing anything
okay so I have a line that wins the
Queen the one that I mentioned check
check and then I'd see - do I have a
mate sure to check it but don't see it
so let's win win the Queen
yeah okay Jim it's not so easy to say I
mean originally I thought that this
position is pretty awful for white maybe
it is not so clear I mean what I think
actually as you shouldn't take am taking
yes it's not really great
you should play I think III and there is
also a form but last time I checked all
this was fine for black but not like
better or anything okay he took and now
the night he gets pushed around 25 yeah
well you can play 96 first and you know
move orders but yeah the interesting
thing is that here group do you want
seems to be better is that my
development is Sam not great I'm curious
about this move what is the point there
take each for at the end is winning the
night okay interesting it's trapped
it's trapped so this move is technically
covering deform which makes it
interesting because this is now on the
cards
but if five is probably also quite good
III hmm yeah Bishop h6 is stronger
because it prevents twin takes you
through as a strong one yeah so you
should take here I mean I'm not very
afraid
in particular I thought this but one
thing that is clear this is also pretty
weak so it's possible that with Knight
age four he will get to a five at least
for example the line
the engine here is giving this thing
here you go here man
it's a pawn but this is also yeah it's
annoying it's an annoying position yeah
he didn't take it and this now looks
completely decisive the after night h4
it should be it should be a 1 it should
be 5 I can't take but there is no
problem with doing this and now thinking
here wins it's just too much bishop a
tool now I'm just winning the Queen with
a check the very Sun opening this year
is quite interesting actually because
there is Bishop f4 for ciabatta played a
lot it's an interesting move that leads
to sometimes I rather unique positions
and this is interesting as well which I
think that in particular c5 is it would
reply after that it feels a lot I think
like I mean it's a chi Goran defense
with the Queens gambit with colors
reversed and quite often in those
position it feels like um yeah black is
this has taking over a little but yeah
as it as why this often in a position in
the against the Chico ring and black has
almost the same thing the tempo doesn't
matter or that much is what I'm trying
the same but yeah why should definitely
not take on c5 that gives me all this
dark square plane that you shouldn't
allow once you have given up the bishop
thanks a lot for watching